[Music]
I mean I've seen a game about about a
week ago and extremely entertaining and
actually interesting game and I thought
that we can develop that one into uh our
topic maybe today maybe today and
another day and probably the larger
topic would be well to trust your
calculation your instincts and not give
in you know to fear that you cannot
really
identify for example I've heard many
times people say yeah I've seen this
continuation it looks I thought it's
very good but well I was scared to play
that and didn't play that and what does
scared to play means really well
obviously it means that there is some
danger in the position but ultimately it
means that you do do not trust yourself
for example maybe the most notable
example what what would it be that a
player says it looks good for me
but I I did not play that when will you
have such
examples for example when the king is in
the
center right when you get the king in
the center and the king is under
attack you don't see how your opponent
gets you but you say ah it's scary what
it really means is you your brain tells
yourself I'm missing something I see
that my king is in the center I see that
it's under attack I think that I'm
better but I don't really trust myself
enough and that's why not playing that
so our topic today maybe next one will
be king in the center or King's under
attack or anything that looks a bit or
more than a bit
scary but the really strong players like
really really strong players they trust
themselves and they know very well what
they are doing and I will not analyze
those too much because they are super
heavily analyzed positions but we will
give each one of them little bit respect
so the first one
is a game this this what inspired me a
game between Grandmaster John Nan one of
the top 10 players in the world through
big part or decent part of the 80 is um
he won several times the world uh
problems solving chess problems solvings
author of some of the greatest books
like too smart of a dude and and seemed
like one of the nicest uh one out there
so when I was young kid I mean he was
tiny bit someone that I was always fun
to look at these games and see he just
nicest dude out there and smartest as
well playing against a player that I do
not know that well uh it's in a weekend
tournament
in England all right so none is white
and this is 1981 E4 C5 Knight F3 Knight
C6
okay
Sicilian Knight
F6 and E5 will get us into the
sikov G6 might get us into some version
of accelerated d or marot if white is
going to play
C4 black play
D5 Knight
B5 Knight F6 well this D6 is another
type of D Sicilian no not allowing the
Knight to go to F6 so not allowing white
to play Bishop G5 in some
versions for example Grand Master team
Mo jaab of one of the top players in the
world was a big fan of this line it's
not considered Mainline Mainline
Sicilian but definitely
playable all
right Knight
F6 so here of course Knight one to C3 is
going to lead
to this FES
nikov D6 Bishop G5 A6 and so
one but interestingly
enough Knight five to C3 was played I'm
not certain I'm a huge fan of this
move 86 okay the perpose of H6 is quite
clear right not allowing white to play
Bishop
G5 because white want to play Bishop G5
eliminate the Knight and positionally
gain control over the the D5 Square I
mean this is not going to be many many
times those position structure Sicilian
yeah but those are the more positional
part of them I don't see why checkmating
here but I see him occupying the square
the defile the D Pawn is a backward Pawn
so A6 I can totally understand white
Play Bishop E3 which I'm okay I'm not
huge fan of this
move I mean I'm not certain why not to
play something like Bishop
C4 would be much more logical to
me Bishop B4
A3 Queen
A5 of course black doesn't want to break
the
pin like that right I mean what does
black have here backward Pawn white pair
of Bishops and black is just worse so
Black's idea is to play this move what
what is Black's threat right
now okay we have to understand what is
black threat in this
position my T pawn my threat black
threat your threat that's that's true
right this is the entire idea by black
and that's why he puts more effort to
keep the pin Bishop C4 if I remember
correctly is the best move and
considered considered just Advantage for
white I I think so but in the
game white took very interesting I mean
I I don't think it's the right move or
I'm at least at least I I'm not certain
why white has to play this way
but white did Bishop C4 looks okay
somewhat maybe sacrificing a pawn in
some
version but with a lot of compensation
after Bishop
C4 so what what what is White's idea in
this position why why did white
sacrifice two points he sacrificed The
Exchange a rook for a bishop
why
oh no no first of all it's white to play
but my question was a general one why
why did white play this move I mean what
is White's big plan white yeah I mean
white is the one that gave material
right when someone is down material or
giving material you always need to ask
either he was forced and then his
position is usually bad or he had a plan
and he sacrificed
it his black queen seem possibly stuck
over
there and with his next move white also
prevents black from castling how can
white how can should white prevent black
from
castling Bishop C5 but Bishop C5 yeah
it's a possibility black might play
B6 it is a possible
move B6 is a
possibility um
yeah white played a bit a bit more
direct but Bishop C5 is the move white
play Queen D6 yeah exactly so that's his
idea now it doesn't seem very
comfortable to develop this
bishop now we can analyze this game
believe me this was I was so fascinated
with this game I I I think I've seen it
for the first time a week ago or two
weeks ago and it's really really fun to
get excited with
such amazing
games well take the pawn is a
possibility white of course is going to
sacrifice some material but white would
like to develop and go after black but
let's get to little bit to our Point
black
took why
took black took the
Knight
okay so really crazy
position but this is just the start
black has all these pieces blocked white
king is already on D2 white is down
technically if you count it four points
of
material but the thing is that black
pieces I mean okay the queen is only
thing that really developed the Knight
is under attack and not easy to think
how to develop the other
pieces which move makes sense here for
black if you're black which which move
would be one of the first moves to
consider Knight to D4 but Knight D4
you're going to lose immediately
right to B4 or
D4 where do you want to
go in the game black played Knight to B4
agree that this was actually played
because this is just losing on the spot
right Queen takes E5 check and then take
here and black position completely
completely
collapsed but when you're under attack
when you not under attack and black is
definitely under attack Under Pressure
what is The Logical way to do exchange
the attacking pieces right you want to
reduce the pressure so Queen B4 is a
very logical
move well the problem is white is just
going to take
take play a move like Bishop
C5 and the problem for black is doesn't
matter if he moves the Knight or defends
with A5 check is going to come and now
if the King goes to one of those squares
white will have a discovered check
taking the Knight the the bishop with
his Knight and if the King goes to d8
the big fork and winning back material
so basically black is losing immediately
m a piece and then you will you can
still tell me hey but ronen black is
going to have enough material he will be
two pieces down but we'll have a rook
and two pawns but that's what chess is
about if it was just about counting 1 2
3 four it would be super simple game
right every kindergarten will learn how
to count the thing is that if without
this Knight black is lost because those
are his pieces
he has no pieces and he cannot really
develop them so it's not just hey what
is the material on the board what the
pieces are doing black really
zero okay there are other continuations
but we will go with our Knight B
before Bishop C5 okay threatening
Checkmate is not
bad here here
here now we are just starting white
King's
March in the analysis none mentioned
that after King D2 Queen C2 the best
outcome should be a draw a bit crazy but
that's what he's he's suggesting like to
St
position but he played queen king
E2 well obviously he's not satisfied
with a
draw and here Knight D5 according to the
analysis is supposed to be winning what
is the difference with the King here on
D2 that the bishop is blocked in many
lines why white Bishop is just blocked
in many lines so they mentioned Queen
takes
E5 King
d8 and Rook f8 defend because Knight
take F7 is not a fork what is it it's a
Checkmate it's a Checkmate it's not a
fork it's a fork but a check and here is
the difference there is no Bishop to
C4 and this is supposed to be winning
for
black so black could have very cool
defended with Knight D5 a bit scary
but most likely winning but black
thought that he's going to play this
check okay he
did and check
again maybe black thought that this is a
draw this way way or was really looking
for a
draw now how many of you would
automatically think about going back I
know I probably would
be but this is where we are you know up
until now it was just an introduction to
this position and to some other examples
we will see today and next
lecture
look white
played this
move yeah I know I I also had this
Twitch in my eye and like seriously but
wait
it's yeah I
mean okay once again no pieces for black
other than those that are developed and
they are far away from the King maybe
the king is safer
here than
here I
mean okay why is threatening
Checkmate and he has
several very big threats in this
position once again big question what is
the first move we are black is under
attack right what's the first logical
instinct to do when you're under attack
check
check but which check we have several
checks first of all and the second one
if you're black would you prefer to have
the Queens off the board or on the board
off right I mean you are under attack
you you want to get rid of attacking
pieces so how can you do that first move
to consider Queen
E6 right but it's not working for black
because after take
take check why is it important check can
white take the Knight
immediately
if white takes the Knight just one
threat for black not too many why why
white cannot take the Knight
immediately which
move F F5 right I mean so if take F5 for
getting back the Knight right so that's
why we have intermediate move moves
check very pretty
one and
take and that's strong enough I mean
once again counting the material black
is all right but looking really at the
position nah black is in bad bad shape
his piece is not easily developed and
black is just in bad
shape 95 is a
possibility
KN D5 is a possibility here but right
has there's like huge huge huge analysis
here that we are not going to touch
right now like huge analysis I think
white is all right after it like
seriously the analysis is over two three
pages analysis just on the Move
95 but that will be missing the target
black played
F5 almost
get
there
now I I've seen a lot of chess games in
my life really a lot but I don't
remember on move 19 I think sometime in
later stages in Middle game obviously
the super famous game Kasparov topalo
where Kasparov sacrificed two Rooks and
toal of King made it all the way here to
be
checkmated I don't don't remember seeing
maybe I can do slowly but not really in
opening stages white King on
F5 when there are quite a lot of pieces
on the board I
mean but you know this this is really
what we are doing here many players
would look at the position and say ah
white is crazy white is a p white
doesn't know how to play chess why
should resign but not a really strong
player you know a strong player like
none look at the
position and objectively analyze it if
all he sees with his eyes is that white
is better here what can he tell himself
I'm not playing it because I'm
scared that's not not not a
possibility and there is a very very
cool line
here if
check take take this is totally okay for
black black is up material and he's
somewhat
alive but this is
incredible white King has an attacking
piece amazing and for example after
Knight
moves how to save The
Rook that's
incredible
right that's how all black pieces are
Stu and white is winning this one this
is really I said it for a reason I
watched this game and I said wow I mean
that's what white had to
play they continue to analyze some other
some other lines here
including a move that is quite
seriously analyzed is I think
knight5 or knight5 after some after King
G6 they Analyze This Knight D5 Knight D5
immediately is being
analyzed well stop stopping Checkmate is
a
start and there just develop cuz when
you are attacking you just want to be
able to bring more attackers if the one
that you have are not sufficient to
finish the game because check the king
just go here but white wants just to
bring
the work to the game and like we said it
is very very difficult for black to
develop
anything black played this move that
looks logical check plus bringing a
piece
back white
took and black play this
move what what is the idea well the
Knight has to move somewhere right and
this is logical why because it is
preventing white king from moving
forward so look again look at this
position it's not a composition it's not
some Blitz game it's Grand Masters
playing which move to play with white
here
Bop D3 Bishop
D3 that's not a bad one
but I wonder what what would black play
after Bishop D3 while white played
something very much in
that
style can I play
check you go
here and if this
move maybe this
wow that's maybe
possible and if check you can reply with
a
check it's amazing yeah I think Bishop
D3 is it looks like it's possible let's
see that we are not that we are not uh
blundering anything just quickly see
that there is
no B6 here is a move they like okay
other than B6 all lines are well working
for black so let's close it so computer
wants to attack the the bishop once
again complicated lines and so on and so
on I I I'm on purpose making effort to
avoid B
calculations much more important is to
prove the
point Bishop D3 okay logical idea
develop and attack the Knight but we see
that the opponent can ignore your threat
but which developing move you can play
here and the opponent cannot ignore
it which is very important we know that
threats are forcing moves right but the
higher the threat is the more forcing it
is one of you going to tell
me excellent job it's the same idea as
Bishop D3 only that instead of attacking
the Knight you're attacking the queen
and he cannot ignore that right when
when I'm here with the kid class
together with
not to be confused with grandmas Ben Fel
our cameraman the one that if not all
the millions of people that are that
will be watching this on
YouTube and he always what what the
millions I said the millions the
millions thousand in attendance and
millions at
homes so for all those we say in the kid
class foring moves check capture threats
and the higher the threat is the more
foring it is threatening Checkmate
threatening the queen okay then down
this is why I like Bishop C4 you know
this logic doesn't change if you're a
10-year-old kid thousand player 1500
player or a grandmas or one of the top
10 players in the world like
none or
like suggesting that we got Bishop C4
excellent Queen
H5 King F4 yeah look at that who is that
attacking who black is getting
checkmated here you want to play G4 okay
that's
it
this
Bic okay here it is quite calul quite
calculation is important here but white
played Queen check
G3 and now white found quite a powerful
way to win the game maybe I'll give you
all again one two minutes see if you
can get the idea I will give you a tiny
clue in chess we really want to trade a
lot of time
material for space or for time that's
what we are trading many many
times right
to
where this move
here what will black play then remember
time is
huge maybe check may maybe it's just
going to develop like this oh man
this is now putting pressure on you next
move is going to play Rook
E8 time time
time which move Knight G5 Knight G5 the
idea is
correct principally but again you have a
very big problem to fight with for
example if you're going to take if black
take you're going to tell me hey Ronan
can't you see it a check mate you will
tell me that right but I see it's a
Checkmate if take check if King here
Checkmate if King
here
check if King goes here
check okay maybe it's Checkmate or
winning the queen because this is the
threat so he has to block this this is
going to be winning for white I don't
know if there
is oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
check
check checkmate yeah I mean but okay you
know sometimes when you you see a game
that continuation that finishes the game
you we are not computers or at least I
will speak for most grand Masters that
are not Magnus Caren or other people we
are not computers so you see a
continuation that let's say computer say
plus five okay my brain shut shuts away
okay winning finish enough and some
people just see always best line of
oudini but that's why they play some
World Championship matches or there
several other super strong players that
are like
that but what is the problem with this
move check it's black black can play
also and black can play
check super important move
developing but more
important making this Square available
for the king so now I'm going to take
and I'm going to have shelter with King
C8
right so Knight G5 is attacking the
queen but not forced enough black has a
check more fing
move now we are
talking Bishop
p7 it has to be taken right because this
we know already it's a Checkmate we have
already been
in this is Checkmate you see when you
are attacking like that just in general
you don't give your opponent a minute to
stand up and breed because well if he
will get his pieces out white king is
not the safest in the world white cannot
allow that so
take check and this is finished that's
that's how the game pretty much
ended not
here this take
back and
resign I mean black doesn't have one
check without losing material this is
winning and look at the blacks how the
pieces
are now other than the fact that this is
a super duper cool game no like really
King on F5 on move
19 well we we have seen some lines that
white king is an attacking piece on move
no not in an end
game right whenever I see the king like
on G7 it's like in soccer on minute 90
one team is down a goal and you know you
need to have every one goal including
the goalkeeper so that's where you get a
king on G7
but my most
important
conclusion that I want to show you from
this game is you
know trust whatever your instincts are
whatever you feel about the position
even if it's scary because you know what
if you are let's say that white was
wrong and you would be checkmated okay
it means that you would have to learn to
calculate better but the great players
that trust themselves what they they
really trust themselves so they say you
know what my king is here here doesn't
matter where I don't see any problems
with that and that's why what I play
I'll show you one more game like this
even with stronger players actually
relatively much stronger
players and even more than none quite a
famous one and like I said this will be
a cool topic to continue for next week
actually I will tiny bit also show The
Other Side how not always getting
because you know you will go home and
say oh R and said get the king in the
center it's good uh
no I said really really best players in
the world and at that time gashimov I
think he was like I don't know number
five six in the world it's 2 and 10 who
who were the number one in the world
okay Caron was one then topalo vanan
Kik maybe someone else maybe Aran and
then gashimov I saw like he I just
mentioned him little bit in previous
lecture such a genius player that due to
medical problems not playing chess
actually for the the last two years and
probably will not
play I mean will be will be really great
for Chess World if he comes back
but so playing in the world team
championship the very strong team of
ajan at that time with rajab of mov I
mean they really three players that were
basically top 10 in the world top 10 top
15 against
Russia again we're not going to analyze
much the game because this game we can
analyze for one month like four lectures
of one hour we can put on this game but
we will see the main
idea KN of Defense so that means we are
going to have a big battle and the
poison Pawn variation meaning insane big
battle um in the world championship
match Fisher lost one game actually was
crushed with the black pieces against
spy with this
line it's known to be one of the most
complicated lines Kasparov has played it
with the black pieces and okay and Anand
has in let's say in the last five years
several big games with white and with
black main Queen D2 is the main line
giving the pawn this way I mean that's
why it's called
the poison Pawn well whether poison or
not we'll
see okay I assume everything is Theory
basically white gave a pawn but what
he's getting we we said he's getting
development some
attack I want to get to the part that we
are that the king starts to be in
danger okay so now black got his Queen
back if white is not going to do
anything spectacular what's going to
happen black is just going to
Castle develop and ask white where is
your compensation at all not not only I
mean if you look at the position it's
not only that white is a pawn down is
horrible Pawn structure so basically in
such situation if white cannot doesn't
have any punch strategically is
lost okay so G4 the idea is that if
Castle is going to play
G5 and drive the Knight back here
because the Knight cannot go here who
will be protecting this pawn and then he
will be targeting this Pawn for example
just just thinking of a possibility
Castle something like this and suddenly
okay no not the prettiest thing what
would happen if this pawn moves up this
is not pretty why
not actually really really not
pretty black is going white is going to
win the game by
playing Knight to D5 right very
important when if white can get the
square many times it's really horrible
for
black okay
H6 Queen H3 he is stubborn right he
wants to go G5 in some moment actually
right now G5 because of the
pin this is a novelty NN stands for
novelty and they mentioned some other
games that were played oh crazy lines I
wonder who are the players in this
some correspondence game and if for
people that are watching it online they
already know my passion to
correspondence game right because
sometimes some strong players not the
best in the world but just decent
players sitting there and they have one
week to play a move or whatever so many
correspondence games are like cars and
level or something like that because you
just have time to process the moves and
so on so I really like when I see
correspondence games it's almost
automatically you know that the quality
is incredible many times if especially
if it top LS okay novelty by Guk very
cool move right he just wants to be able
to take and have the roof protected but
okay let's get back to our big topic so
white is making whatever efforts to open
the game because remember from previous
game if you are down
material and you are not planning to
play Fast well why are you down material
well okay so here we
start would you believe me if I tell you
that this
king is going to make its way to
here this king is going to make its way
all the way there and black is going to
win one of the most brilliant
games that's a first move
right maybe maybe now we should say you
know instead of uh we can say in the
chest word also King's journey to a from
E8 to A2 starts with King D7 so here
it's starting
this okay
h8 Bishop F4 they say is a mistake but
okay we are not I don't want to analyze
it too much I want to
go Queen D5 let's stop here for a
second what did we say in the previous
game when you are under attack what is
the best way to or one of the best ways
to defend
exchange so those principle those ideas
should not will not change from thousand
other games and that's why the reason
why I'm not analyzing them is because it
will just miss the point this game is so
complicated I want to touch the
principles okay another
move moving
away
check
okay okay but black is up material and
black knows that if he's not going to be
checkmated he going to win the game
right if black is not checkmated he
going to win the game this is one
thing he needs to be careful not to give
back too much material and where is the
best spot for his King right now well
he's going away from White pieces this
this is where white pieces are it's
amazing A3 was
played so what is White's idea if
take take with a
check why and here here trouble because
the material is not so much in White in
Black's favor anymore just few pawns I I
say quite a lot what is the great thing
when your opponent is sacrificing you
and you get a lot of material the that
you can give back the material and not
be checkmated and hopefully sacrificing
is basically an investment think about
it you sacrifice a rook what does it
mean it means that you right now pay
Five Points to have an
attack if the if to stop the attack the
opponent has to give you seven points of
material then you want two points of
material if the opponent can completely
stop your attack and only give you back
a bishop you probably lost so sacrifice
is really an investment depends on if if
it's right or wrong depends just like
any investment what price you are paying
so here the price for white attack seems
quite okay he three pawns down but black
seems like can be in trouble
here so what did grishuk
play King
up what is the threat that now if take
he's going to take the bishop on
D3 and if take here okay you can say hey
it looks like the previous position yes
only
that the price that white pays for
having black king there now is
substantially
more
take
amazing but
black trust
himself doesn't see how white is winning
obviously those are really really best
players in the world of
course very important intermediate
move so he can drive the White Queen cuz
White Queen here was perfect preventing
check on E5 preventing check on
A1
yeah here they say this is
winning stopping Rook F3 and if B5 what
is the idea of B5 maybe check and
opening attack against the king just to
open Line black stops all possibilities
to open
lines this
this
the King has reached its destination so
we made it all the way from here to here
but it's white attack that is probably
fading away here this move getting the
rook in the
game check
block ex change but that just means that
the game is over for example
here easiest way to win simplify why
black is up Material Exchange everything
I mean okay Rook C2 winning the queen I
went looking at that was just thinking
super quickly about take I didn't even
look at the other continuation
check this is where I stopped thinking
just taking the pawn and winning okay
doesn't
matter
and and black and white
resigned again this game so much
analysis we could have done what is our
point the previous game was in my view
even a bit Wilder because white tiny bit
voluntarily actually
went
here black got a lot of material he got
paid and had to start moving his King in
the other position white kind of didn't
have to do that those were two very
successful games
of strong players in this example and
previous one absolutely best in the
world top 10 That We're Not Afraid we
will see several more of those examples
of Not Afraid and just to make a tiny
bit tiny bit how to put it like in
perspective some games that actually won
tiny bit needs to be worried when his
King is taken to such a
[Music]
journey
[Applause]
oh